موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم تفقد وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجيو شويغو مقر تجمع القوات
الروسيه المعروف باسم قوات الشرق في منطقه
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
وقالت وزاره الدفاع ان الوزيره شويجو او
الاهتماما خاصه لتنظيم الدعم الشامل
للقوات المشاركه في العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه
قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان وفدا يضم
ويندي شارما النائبه وزير الخارجيه
ومسؤولين من مجلس الامن القومي ووزاره
الدفاع زار العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف للقاء
الرئيس فوليد ميرسي وعدد من المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين وذكرت الخارجيه ان الوفد جدد
تاكيده على التزام واشنطن الثابته تجاهك
ضد العدوان الروسي غير المبرر
كما زار المدير العام لوكاله الطاقه
الذريه رافايل روسي محطه للطاقه النوويه
في مقاطعه ميكو لايف جنوب اوكرانيا وقال
جروسي ان زيارته تهدف لضمان السلامه
والامن النوويين وان الوكاله ستكون حاضره
بشكل دائم في جميع محطات الطاقه
الاوكرانيه لمنع وقوع اي حادث نووي في ظل
استمرار الصراع
قال الكرملين ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوت بحثا مع نظيره التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
ملف انشاء مركز لتوزيع الغازي في تركيا
وقال مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
للجزيره ان روسيا فقدت مصداقيتها كمورد
موثوق للطاقه بعد استخدامها كادت حرب
في اول رساله مصوره منذ اعلان اثره نشرت
كتائب القسام الذراع المسلح لحركه حماس
مقطع فيديو يظهر الاسير الاسرائيلي لديها
ابرى من جيستو وبينما طالبت عائلته الاسير
باطلاق سراحله بشكل فوري قال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ان نشر
الفيديو خدعه ستؤخر فرصه التوصل لصفقه
لتبادل الاسرى
طالب 39 دوله في الامم المتحده اسرائيل
بالتراجع الفوري عن الاجراءات العقابيه
التي اتخذتها ضد الفلسطينيين وابدات الدول
في بيان مشترك لفظها الاجراءات التي لجات
اليها اسرائيل ردا على طلب فتوى بمحكمه
العدل الدوليه حول الاستيطان وانتهاك
اسرائيل المستمر لحق الفلسطينيين
قال وكيل الامين العام للامم المتحده
مارتن غريفيث ان الوضع الامني في اليمن لا
يزال شديد الصعوبه بالنسبه للعاملين في
المجال الانساني وكشف جريفيث عن تعرض
الوكالات الانسانيه العامله في اليمن
العام الماضي لنحو 150 حادث
لاول مره منذ نحو سته عقود سجلت الصين
تراجعا في عدد السكان خلال العام الماضي
وفق ما اظهرته بياناته الرسميه وافاد
المكتب الوطني للاحصاءات ان عدد سكان خفض
بنسبه صفر فاصله 85% مقارنه بعام 2020
وبلغ عدد السكان خلال العام الماضي مليارا
و400 واحد عشره مليون
و750,000 ختام الموجز في امان الله